[Música]
el candidato líder de la izquierda
colombiana gustavo petro y rodolfo
hernández un candidato independiente que
sorprendió en las urnas serán quienes
disputen la segunda vuelta presidencial
en colombia que será llevada a cabo el
19 de junio ya lo hemos dicho colombia
es un escenario muy particular para
estas citas electorales porque tiene
todavía un conflicto interno hay
presencia de grupos armados la forma en
que los políticos hacen política y
también se presentan extremos
ideológicos así como figuras de mucho
peso muy fuertes en términos políticos y
otros que se mantienen pese a su
debilidad política pero en esta
oportunidad lo que queda claro en este
resultado de esta primera vuelta en
colombia es que los colombianos quieren
un cambio un cambio que se aleje de la
política tradicional de los partidos
tradicionales de las maquinarias del
formalismo del clientelismo o un cambio
que se aleje de los tradicionales
valores de la derecha que históricamente
ha gobernado en ese país suramericano
veamos entonces los resultados de esta
primera vuelta de acuerdo al conteo
oficial de la registraduría nacional del
estado civil que es encargada de
organizar en términos logísticos estos
comicios en colombia gustavo petro del
pacto histórico como ven es la coalición
de izquierda obtuvo un 8.5 millones de
votos como para redondear eso equivale a
un 40 32% le sigue a rodolfo hernández
quien obtuvo 59 millones de votos eso
equivale a 28 el 15 por ciento de las
votaciones
pues estos son los dos candidatos que
van a disputarse esa segunda vuelta
ambos dieron unas palabras a sus
seguidores a sus votantes en el caso de
gustavo petro fue un discurso largo en
el que defendió su programa de gobierno
también lo que representa para la
izquierda colombiana estar en la
posición en la que está en este momento
y llamó a hacer alianzas y también a
buscar ese millón de votos adicionales
que necesita para llegar a la silla
presidencial en la casa de nariño estas
fueron sus palabras
nosotros queremos un cambio que
construye aquí paz
que acabe la violencia porque lo que
buscamos es una colombia potencia
mundial de la vida así que
estamos a un millón de votos de ganar
[Música]
un millón de votos más
estos 8 millones y medio de lectores si
esta cifra cambia el 8 por un 9
ganamos
en un escenario muy distinto contrario a
este evento multitudinario en un
prestigio prestigioso tele de bogotá la
capital colombiana cuando estábamos
acostumbrados a ver a gustavo petro en
las plazas con estos baños de masa
rodolfo hernández permaneció en su
residencia campestre en piedecuesta que
hace parte del área metropolitana de la
ciudad de bucaramanga en el oriente
colombiano hernández leyó unas palabras
escritas a mano desde la cocina de su
casa invitó evitó perdón e ir a su sede
de campaña también sus palabras fueron
pues enrutadas más a agradecer a los
votantes a reiterar su compromiso con
ellos y evitó referirse a los otros
partidos a las coaliciones a referirse
incluso a su futuro contrincante gustavo
petro escuchemos
con la votación que obtuvo mi propuesta
de gobierno hoy ganó la nación del
trabajo hoy ganas ganó la nación de la
honestidad hoy ganó el país que no
quiere seguir ni un solo día más con los
mismos y las mismas que nos han llevado
a la situación dolorosa en que hoy
estamos ahora entramos al segundo tiempo
y estos próximos días serán decisivos
para determinar el futuro del país soy
consciente de la necesidad de unir
nuestro país en el camino de cambio que
hoy se ha hecho evidente
contundentemente
y soy consciente de las dificultades que
vendrán cuando asuma la presidencia de
la república
ya vemos a los dos candidatos pero
entonces como queda configurada esta
segunda vuelta presidencial en colombia
como va a ser ese reparto de los apoyos
de los candidatos que no pasaron a la
segunda vuelta pero entonces apelará a
la política tradicional que tanto
criticó y buscará apoyos sea como sea
hernández se va a mantener entonces en
su poca tradicional manera de hacer
política lejos de las alianzas lejos de
los partidos tradicionales y en las
grandes figuras políticas como sienten
los colombianos el cambio que están a la
vuelta de la esquina de comenzar a
experimentar porque sea como sea
representa un cambio en la página
política de ese país que se puede decir
también del proceso democrático
colombiano del papel de las mujeres
porque sea quien sea el presidente de
colombia lo que sí es seguro es que
colombia va a tener una vicepresidenta
afrodescendiente por primera vez en su
historia el análisis post jornada
electoral y también el escenario de cara
a esta segunda vuelta presidencial en
colombia en nuestro tema de análisis
aquí en france24 y para analizar y
comentar este tema saludamos en bogotá
en la capital colombiana a mónica pachón
ella es doctora en ciencia política y
docente de la universidad de los andes
en la ciudad de bogotá y desde
washington en eeuu se conecta a esta
conversación y gimena sánchez garza lee
ella es líder de la sección para la
defensa de los derechos humanos de wv y
el perdón en colombia ustedes nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de esta
conversación ya lo saben pueden dejar
todos sus comentarios a través de las
redes sociales en facebook en instagram
y en twitter no se encuentran como
france24
s también nos pueden encontrar en
nuestra señal en streaming en youtube
también encuentran mi cuenta personal
arroba santi logo nuestra etiqueta es
numeral efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas para que
participen en este tema en este análisis
post electoral en colombia comienza
entonces dándole la bienvenida a mónica
pachón en la ciudad de bogotá mónica
muchas gracias por acompañarnos en el
programa y en la jornada de hoy y
comienzo como punto de partida del
debate como siempre me gusta llamarlo el
punto de partida su balance de la
jornada aspectos para destacar aspectos
que deben ser revisados con lupa
bueno santiago yo creo que uno de los
principales puntos de conclusión de ayer
es que los colombianos votaron en contra
de los partidos políticos y en contra de
la colectividad votaron a favor de dos
personas pues que tienen un movimiento
alrededor de ellos que no tienen una
organización consolidada
e incluiría a federico gutiérrez en esa
misma lista
cuál es el balance
político pues para petro el tener el 40
por ciento de la popularidad en esta
elección es importante pero es
insuficiente para él hubiera sido más
fácil las encuestas mostraban que
federico gutiérrez podría ser más fácil
lo podría vencer más fácil en segunda
vuelta pero el señor rodolfo hernández
le sacó la ventaja y efectivamente
tienen los dos una agenda anti política
los dos un discurso que que se parece
bastante y el discurso de petro tendría
que cambiar para rodolfo hernández el
balance supremamente positivo sacó 28
por ciento de los votos y tiene el apoyo
de enrique gómez ingrid betancourt
federico gutiérrez ayer mismo ellos
declaran su apoyo
y saludo ahora a jimena sánchez gasol y
en la ciudad de washington es punto de
partida del debate su balance jimena
bienvenida al programa gracias por
acompañarnos puntos a destacar puntos
para revisar con lupa este proceso
electoral en colombia bueno muchas
gracias santiago y saludos a ti y tus
televidentes bueno la gran sorpresa fue
rodolfo hernández dijo él estaba ganando
espacio estos últimos dos semanas y
realmente no fue el enfoque de todo el
mundo que estaba pidiendo esto y la gran
sorpresa fue que él logró llegar a la
segunda vuelta
ahora la antipolítica que hemos visto en
filipinas en eeuu en otras partes ha
llegado a colombia y la pregunta es qué
tipo de antipolítica quieren los
colombianos en cierta manera ahora
gustavo petro que siempre era como la
oposición y lo alternativo es como el
candidato más establecido es en términos
de las reglas de política en colombia y
rodolfo hernández es una una
representación de un fenómeno de las
medias sociales pero también el
descontento amplio que había frente como
se está política en colombia entonces
vamos a un periodo de mucha
incertidumbre
si extrañamente o paradójicamente mejor
decirlo así y gustavo petro pasa ahora a
representar un poco la institucionalidad
y lo tradicional y rodolfo hernández
pasa a representar un cambio en la forma
incluso hacer política ya lo mencionaba
yo en un discurso escrito a mano muy
corto muy puntual desde su cocina en su
casa campestre y no como estos grandes
baños de masa que normalmente hacen los
políticos o por lo menos de lo que vemos
en la política colombiana ya vamos a
analizar ese punto quiero es cerrar este
punto de partida con la necesidad que
estamos mencionando de los dos
candidatos de crecer en sus votaciones
ambos tienen que crecer un rodolfo
hernández dice que necesitas llegar
hasta unos 12 millones de votos eso
requiere muchísimo apoyo de los votantes
colombianos y de los candidatos que se
quedaron en la primera ronda gustavo
petro dice que necesita un millón
puede ser ese crecimiento de ambos
candidatos el comienzo por jimena para
hacer la ronda a la inversa
bueno ya hemos escuchado de federico
gutiérrez y de sergio fajardo los
médicos gutiérrez ha dicho básicamente
que quiere que la gente que votó por él
vote por rodolfo hernández eso sería
muchísimo y llegaría y podría ganar con
esto con también si la parte de sergio
fajardo decide votar para el mismo que
perdió para todo digo que cada uno tiene
que hacerlo lo que sí es cierto es que
ambos candidatos tienen que cambiar sus
discursos para ser mucho más abiertos a
las oposiciones mucho más diferentes de
los que han presentado hasta este
momento porque de cierta manera uno
puede decir que peto llegó a su tope
llegó un poco más en la última vez que
se hizo este ejercicio pero no tanto
entonces la pregunta es qué va a ser él
para ganar estos otros votantes son con
rotor fernández cómo va a ser el para
dar confianza a los que votaron para
otros que él es ahora es un candidato él
es tan poco conocido considerando un pop
que se desmarca algunas formaciones
tradicionales colombianas como los
partidos liberal conservador y que se
desmarca también del uribismo que ha
sido muy controvertido en estas en estas
elecciones y mónica su opinión cómo van
a crecer aquí los dos tienen que entrar
a hacer este juego político de alianzas
acercarse o por lo menos conversar con
otros con otras personas que
corresponden al espectro político
colombiano cómo va a ser ese
rompecabezas que es tal vez la llave de
la silla presidencial para llegar a la
silla presidencial de la casa de nariño
pues santiago aquí hay varias preguntas
que todavía no tenemos respuesta el 55
por ciento de los colombianos salió a
votar esto es un 7 por ciento más de lo
que salían a votar en elecciones
legislativas para petro sería importante
elevar en la participación en ciudad él
es muy popular en ciudad de bogotá sacó
casi el 50 por ciento de la votación
entonces si él quisiera crecer le
tocaría a sacar a los abstencionistas y
a las personas que no salen usualmente a
votar eso es una estrategia muy
arriesgada y muy compleja porque él ya
había sumado una cantidad de personas
precisamente anticipando esto de no
ganar en primera vuelta para el caso del
candidato rodolfo hernández es pues
tiene una imagen positiva mucho más
positiva es decir que tiene todavía no
ha llegado a su techo y por el otro lado
pues ya hay muchísimas personas que se
mueven en el anti petr ismo y que muy
seguramente se van a pasar a rodolfo
hernández a esa campaña a pesar de no
conocerlo cuál es el truco y que tendría
que hacerlo de fernández desmarcarse de
todos esos apoyos es muy difícil y hay
que mirar qué hace petro pero está
diciendo que es un populista que no
tiene experiencia
que es un ignorante y pues que es un
salto al vacío y que él representa pues
un estadista y una persona que respeta
la institucionalidad entonces ya
empezamos a ver un cambio de discurso
claro es un cambio de curso pero que
también lo veíamos en la campaña previa
esa primera vuelta a los ataques
constantes a los otros candidatos
veíamos como por ejemplo petro
señalaba fuertemente a fajardo y hoy en
día pues esos 800.000 votos que tuvo
fajardo le pueden venir muy bien a petro
pero pero fue constante el ataque a esa
campaña de la coalición del centro ahora
empieza entonces los acercamientos
podrían ir por ahí quiero hablar del
caso rodolfo hernández jimena de su
estrategia de redes tal vez se le está
mostrando a los colombianos esa forma
distinta de hacer política de no
pertenecer a los partidos tradicionales
no estar financiado por maquinarias ni
por empresarios ni por un sector
económico en particular y con una
campaña simplemente redes sociales pero
que logró calar en la gente y logró
cautivar a buena parte del oriente del
país que son zonas rurales son zonas
apartadas de grandes sitios urbanos y
eso dice mucho del estilo en el que
rodolfo hernández se ha aproximado a la
gente su forma de hablar su forma de
comportarse
bueno yo pienso que cuando gustavo petro
en su discurso de ayer después de las
elecciones dijo que de manera
despreciada que era como candidato de
'tik tok' pienso que es un gran error
porque yo pienso de esa estrategia
realmente ha sido muy buena si uno mira
muchas de la gente que lo está apoyando
y las regiones que estamos hablando ahí
las cosas corren más por vos y corren
más por ese sentido más tradicional noté
que alguien está haciendo como con un
auto diciendo estas son mis propuestas y
una cosa cuatro veces a la vez y sin
mucho detalle entonces esta era como una
forma más técnica y más moderna de hacer
eso que además llegó a muchos más
jóvenes entonces yo pienso que esta
estrategia de redes sociales hay que
realmente analizar lo que pienso que
puede han sido algo muy positivo y
también demuestra de que muchos
colombianos están cansados de la
formalidad que se ve mucho en los
centros del país como bogotá y todo
demás psicotécnico y los que quieren es
respuestas a sus situaciones y
respuestas muy directas y mucho planes y
mucha larga historia
y mónica cuál es su impresión su opinión
sobre esta campaña de rodolfo hernández
redes sociales un lenguaje sencillo
algunas veces muy directo con sus
afirmaciones y también digámoslo un poco
despistado hay varias frases que han
comenzado a hacer memes incluso en las
redes sociales que ya pasan a ser parte
de la cultura colombiana por sus
desatinos en algunos comentarios
me parece muy interesante el comentario
de jimena y me adhiero y santiago yo
haya añadiría que pues por un lado está
la estrategia de redes sociales y de
hacer una cantidad digamos de
afirmaciones
yo diría irresponsables populistas pero
que llaman la atención de la población
de una forma pues importante pues porque
todo el mundo está aburrido del
privilegio que tienen los políticos
tradicionales y se sienten y pues se
sienten agobiados y
desesperanzados con este tipo de fuerza
política pero además diría que mucha
gente alude a lo último es abandonó los
otros candidatos y cogieron a arroz
fernández como un default dieron bueno
este señor está sumando y yo no quiero
ni el uribismo ni el petismo entonces
aquí en el mes 1 me sumo a rudolf
fernández y creo que el voto de rodolfo
hernández también acumula una cantidad
de votantes que no tenían ningún interés
en que fuera federico o fuera rodolfo
entonces él logra también capturar un
voto que es un voto de tercería lo que
es no uribismo no pétriz sí entonces
básicamente es un castigo
al uribismo al presidente de edu que
también podríamos incluirlo a y mónica
un castigo al sistema no les gustaba lo
que ofrecía la derecha ni la izquierda
pero el centro tampoco logró
consolidarse fuertemente que ya lo vamos
a analizar más adelante se consolida
esto entonces como un castigo lo ve
usted así yo sí creo yo creo que aquí
hay un castigo también a la izquierda
y hay un castigo al al a lo tradicional
entonces pues sale rodolf hernández
atacando también a petro diciendo usted
se está uniendo con políticos
tradicionales como son armando benedetti
y no estos roy barreras una cantidad de
personas que son super cuestionables
usted no puede luchar contra la
corrupción si tiene estas personas al
lado un sí y además lo acusa a vivir del
estado y pues eso es algo que a todo el
mundo le parece sensato en el mundo de
la antipolítica y pues sale a este
populismo derecha que es
ya en las regiones ya lo teníamos
nosotros teníamos candidatos
independientes en todas las ciudades y
gobernaciones faltaba la presidencia y
aquí está
exactamente pasemos ahora al candidato
gustavo petro jimena para analizar su
discurso cómo va a ser esa búsqueda de
apoyos que tan consolidada ve usted a la
izquierda colombiana para llegar al
poder entendiendo el antecedente de este
país no una guerra de más de cinco
décadas precisamente por los movimientos
y las guerrillas de izquierda contra el
estado un estado que siempre ha sido del
centroderecha dependiendo de la época y
el contexto político en el que esté pero
está la izquierda colombiana consolidada
en esta coalición del pacto histórico
con gustavo petro para para enfrentar la
presidencia de colombia
bueno de izquierda en cualquier parte
del mundo nunca está completamente
consolidada porque siempre hay muchas
fragmentaciones y opiniones pero en este
caso yo pienso que lo ven como a él como
el candidato él llama mucho a esa
colombia que siente que casi se perdió
la paz del todo con duke esa colombia
que fue a protestar en las calles
después de una pandemia tan feroz y
efectos económicos tan graves esa
colombia que también estuvo muy enojada
por la respuesta desproporcionada de la
policía y les mata a la gente
protestando y también esa colombia que
sabe que el modelo económico no está
llegando a todo el mundo en el país y
hay que cambiarlo mismo si no están
seguros exactamente cómo cambiarlo yo
veo que la oposición más grande que
puede tener peso no es tanto en colombia
pero fuera del país mirándolo aquí desde
washington dice aquí hay mucho
preocupación sobre las posturas de
gustavo petro en términos de cómo puede
cambiar la relación económica cómo puede
cambiar la forma en que eeuu está
mirando al tema de venezuela y eso causa
un poco de miedo fernández se ve como
que seguramente va a seguir la misma
postura que ha habido siempre el mismo
dijo que iba a ganar lo bueno y dejar lo
malo entonces yo pienso que mirando lo
que la élite colombiana y económica está
mirando o petro como cómo quedará
colombia frente al resto del mundo y con
su aliado principal
en la región y en el mundo que es
estados unidos eso también puede tener
una influencia
en cerca de su compañía bueno esa teoría
suya jimena se válida con los resultados
en el exterior en donde ganó federico
gutiérrez en casi todos los países en
donde hay una gran diáspora colombiana y
en donde pudieron votar en los
diferentes embajadas y consulados y pues
también es evidente
con el casi millón y medio de
venezolanos que han llegado al
territorio colombiano procedentes de
venezuela en donde hay una situación
económica complicada mónica su opinión
sobre la izquierda esta consolidación de
gustavo petro en el escenario político
colombiano de esta conformación de este
pacto que él ha llamado pacto histórico
esta coalición con mucho con digamos un
prisma de izquierdas muy variadas
bueno yo quisiera plantear una
lectura un poco distinta de decir que es
la izquierda yo creo que es gustavo
petro cierto en colombia hemos tenido
políticas de izquierda juan manuel
santos firmó un proceso de paz que
reconocía errores estructurales del
estado
juan manuel santos hizo una justicia
transicional que es súper generosa a los
victimarios también digamos que nosotros
hemos tenido políticas de izquierda pero
no hemos tenido ha gustado petro que ha
sido candidato del de la izquierda
pero de muchos partidos colombia humana
polo democrático ahora pacto histórico
son más un movimiento social
consolidados no yo veo ha gustado petro
en el centro de una organización que le
falta consolidación no sabemos muy bien
cómo se conforma el equipo los
congresistas que lo acompañan no tienen
experiencia legislativa entonces yo creo
que es frágil en la medida en que
depende mucho del líder ahí se parecen
inclusive al uribismo en ese sentido en
sus primeros pasos entonces yo sí creo
que aquí hay un dilema y por otro lado
pues hay muchas voces dentro de ese
dentro de este grupo que por ejemplo
promocionan la falta de
institucionalización ayer armando
benedetti duro todo el día diciendo que
había fraude electoral que no habían
garantías que les iban a robar las
elecciones es decir ahí nos lectura no
es tan positiva en ese sentido porque yo
creo que no es una organización
consolidada aún y que creo que la hagan
la eso genera aún más incertidumbre en
la política macro y también digamos en
las políticas en otros en otras áreas de
sectores
de las que no sabemos qué puede hacer
claro
hay una un escenario muy particular para
estos dos candidatos y es que los dos se
muestran como anti políticos la
corrupción es como uno de sus temas
principales de campaña pero ya lo decía
mónica gustavo petro tiene unos
personajes alrededor que son muy
cuestionados
dentro del escenario político colombiano
por su desempeño por su relacionamiento
por las personas que los han rodeado
pero también está el caso de hernández
que está siendo investigado por un
presunto caso de corrupción cuando fue
alcalde de bucaramanga que es la capital
de un departamento en colombia como
entiende uno mónica que estos dos
antisistema santi políticos y con lucha
anti corrupción están siendo
investigados o tan mal relacionados en
el caso de petro con personajes muy
cuestionados
pues yo creo que en colombia es
costumbre digamos hay todos los
personajes que están en la política
terminan con investigaciones esto es
típico en los alcaldes en los
gobernadores sergio fajardo inclusive
también tenía investigaciones
lo que a mí me parece grave obviamente
es que estemos en un proceso judicial en
donde el señor hernández tiene que
presentarse ante las autoridades se está
hablando de una posible caso de
nepotismo en donde su hijo era a la
vista de una organización de una empresa
para prestar un servicio a la ciudad y
pues hay evidencias que lo que lo
comprometen en el caso de gustavo petro
es un poquito esa necesidad de acercarse
a otros sectores políticos y al
establecimiento para darle tranquilidad
a los empresarios para darle
tranquilidad a la élite de que la
llegada a gustavo petro no significa un
cambio radical y revolucionario pero en
esa en esas alianzas obviamente pierden
pierde gustado petro porque pues por
fernández se la saca en cara a todos los
días y pues lo mismo así hacer un fardo
y lo mismo hacía
gutiérrez con un poquito menos de
autoridad moral y yo creo que lo que va
a pasar con rodolfo hernández en este
caso va a ser crucial para su elección
jimena también llama la atención de esta
primera vuelta presidencial y de cara a
este balotaje el 19 de junio es la
ausencia de los partidos tradicionales
colombia estaba habituada al partido
liberal al partido conservador y a los
movimientos alrededor de ellos y casi
siempre a movimientos
en cierta forma de centro y de derecha
esto que dice la democracia colombiana
que dice del proceso político colombiano
entendiendo de nuevo el contexto un país
en conflicto sumamente polarizado con
unas diferencias sociales muy grandes en
donde pues prácticamente las élites en
burbuja das de bogotá y de las capitales
son las que han gobernado el país
bueno desde mi punto de vista esto ya
venía sucediendo después del acuerdo de
paz por la apertura que dio el acuerdo
de paz a diferentes expresiones
políticas que normalmente no eran parte
de ese pacto como primero de comunes
pero también estas curules de paz
entonces yo pienso que es esta dirección
en que los partidos tradicionales no son
más el centro total de la historia de
política en colombia ya estaba yendo en
esta dirección anterior a estas
elecciones y esta selección es realmente
consolidaron que esos esos partidos no
son los que tienen el mayor control
si mónica su opinión sobre esta ausencia
de los partidos tradicionales y también
del uribismo se cierra entonces un
capítulo del uribismo en el poder en
colombia
yo diría que no yo diría que el uribismo
es una fuerza consolidada tienen
bancadas en el congreso de la república
tienen alcaldes tienen gobernadores y
por supuesto tienen una historia que
contar es tan maltrechos pero se pueden
recuperar en el tiempo dependiendo del
desempeño del gobierno y así nosotros
oscila vamos entre no anti uribistas
uribistas y esto ha sido lo que ha
pasado en los últimos años en los
últimos años en la política colombiana
yo creo que como decía jimena esto es
una tendencia que se ha venido
consolidando pero lo que le dio el jaque
mate a los partidos y su rol en estas
elecciones fueron las consultas
interpartidarias y la participación de
independientes de forma masiva para la
presidencia de la república eso
realmente para mí ha sido un drama en
términos de tener dos sistemas políticos
uno para el ejecutivo y otro para el
legislativo entonces creo que los
partidos políticos
día a día de la justifica colombiana es
decir consejos de asambleas de diputados
e inclusive el congreso van a ser y van
a seguir siendo importantes y es ese es
el reto de cómo volver a tener un
sistema político en donde parte ni sea
el ejecutivo no signifique ser
independiente y esto tiene que ver con
las reglas electorales y pues estas
consultas interpartidarias masivas en
marzo mataron el rol de los partidos en
esta en esta ocasión pero también lleva
a buscar esos consensos entre las
diferentes fuerzas políticas que eso
también puede ser en cierta forma
saludable para una democracia
jimena hablemos del proceso como tal
veníamos de unas elecciones legislativas
con una registraduría muy cuestionada
por el proceso del conteo de los votos
hubo señalamientos los mismos candidatos
ya venían un poco allanando ahí con sus
comentarios y dificultades a la hora de
entregar resultados y ayer yo creo que
la registraduría dejó callado al país
entero porque en solamente dos horas ya
tenía completamente contabilizado los
votos más del 90 por ciento de las mesas
y ya se sabía quiénes eran los dos
candidatos que pasaban a esa segunda
vuelta en un tiempo muy rápido y bueno
incluso los candidatos avalaron el
proceso como ve usted el proceso como
tal la rapidez en la entrega de los
votos la logística y bueno las encuestas
también acertaron también hay que hablar
de las encuestas que daban a
hernández y a petro en esa segunda
vuelta
bueno yo pienso que el otro ganador de
las elecciones fue registrador que
estaba muy mal señalado por todo lo que
pasó durante marzo 13 con las elecciones
al congreso y el tema de los votos y el
escrutinio y había muchos llamados de
que renuncie y también ya se estaba
diciendo por diferentes actores
importantes en la vida colombiana como
los presidentes anteriores de que iba a
haber fraude en estas elecciones yo
pienso que el hecho que se hizo tan
rápido y se hizo tan bien y lo que se ha
reportado hasta ahora no es
increíblemente grave
muestra que realmente se pusieron las
pilas entonces eso es positivo
ahora yo me pregunto qué va a pasar en
la segunda vuelta si el margen entre los
dos candidatos
es muy cercano suena y me pregunto si
tal vez va a haber más cuestionamiento y
desconfianza del sistema de traslado esa
pregunta mónica que piensa usted mónica
ese escenario un estrecho margen de
diferencia entre los dos candidatos
que tanta confianza puede haber en la
autoridad electoral en colombia a raíz
de lo que ha sucedido y bueno y se
reivindicaron ayer
yo creo que se reivindicaron ayer pero
no tanto el registrador sino la
registraduría como institución el
registrador fue muy soberbio mucho ver
vio en marzo cometió un error muy básico
no hubiera podido explicar de una forma
más sencilla y en cambio decidió acusar
a los jurados a hacer un escándalo decir
que iba a haber un reconteo general
entrar en una crisis institucional
absolutamente innecesaria creo que lo
que pasó ayer es lo que ha venido
pasando durante muchos ciclos
electorales en colombia la elección
presidencial siempre es más sencilla
tenemos resultados a tiempo entonces
bueno veremos eso ahora que puede pasar
en una elección de margen cercano pues
al tetris mo que es el que ha venido
cuestionando las elecciones ciudad que
ha dicho que no reconocería los
resultados le toca seguir manteniendo
ese discurso que es un discurso muy
difícil cuando uno está en contra de
otro antisistema como vamos a decir que
el sistema está no todo mancomunado
y haciendo fraude a favor de hernández
me parece muy extraño entonces yo creo
que él les va a tocar simplemente hacer
lo que han venido haciendo testigos
electorales en todas las mesas y hacer
una operación muy importante para seguir
los votos y estar tranquilos en el en el
escrutinio para pues para mantener la
democracia pero como dice ximena esos
márgenes pequeños siempre generan
problemas en personas que dicen no
reconocer los resultados como es el caso
de gustavo petro en contadas ocasiones
que puede ser un escenario muy posible
de cara a esos resultados presidenciales
ya vamos llegando a la parte final del
programa quiero hablar y cerrar hablando
de la participación redondeando es más o
menos 21,5 millones de personas votaron
pero muchos analistas hoy en los medios
colombianos hablan que podría haber una
alta abstención para esa segunda vuelta
precisamente porque muchas personas no
se identifican con ninguno de los dos
candidatos y pues preferirían no votar
mónica para hacer la ronda a la inversa
usted qué piensa de esas afirmaciones
como ve el escenario
pues yo creo que están otorgándole al
ala a los votantes un nivel de
indignación que de pronto no van a tener
yo creo que ante la incertidumbre veamos
hay que mirar las siguientes encuestas
estas encuestas si nos muestran márgenes
muy estrechos y empates técnicos entre
los candidatos yo creo que la gente va a
tender a participar este esta
participación fue histórica 55 por
ciento mucha gente dice que le favorece
la abstención ha gustado petro pero yo
lo que creo es que
dada la incertidumbre los votantes
tienden a salir entonces pues no sé yo
diría que yo también estaba pensando que
en esta elección iban a ver a los votos
en blanco del 5% nulidad alrededor del
4% y lo que vimos fue absolutamente nada
de votos en blanco menos del 2% y
también un margen de votos nulos muy muy
muy chiquito entonces creo que los
votantes no están indignados sino que
quieren tomar decisiones y jimena su
opinión sobre este tema ya para el
cierre cómo se comporta el votante
colombiano nos vemos vuelto un poco más
rigurosos y más comprometidos con la
democracia con este deber ciudadano como
lo ve
bueno yo estoy de acuerdo con lo que
dijo la profesora y yo también está muy
sorprendida que el voto en blanco fue
tan bajo yo esperaba mucho más alto y
tiene razón eso hubiese mostrado más
indignación ahora el tema de si cuanto
más personas votarían en la segunda
vuelta no sabemos por qué mundialmente
hemos visto que también aquí en eeuu y
en otras partes del mundo menos gente ve
el sistema de votar como realmente la
forma de participar completamente en
política y entonces yo pienso que va a
depender mucho de cómo va la situación
si hay algún acto
determinante entre ahora
119 que impulsa esas otra gente a votar
no creo que va a ser tanto los
candidatos
consiguiendo que más gente vote pero más
la circunstancia en que nos vemos en dos
semanas pues a jimena sánchez garcía
mónica pachón les agradezco mucho por
este análisis por mostrarnos esta foto
del panorama electoral en colombia de
cara a esa segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios y todas
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales y por supuesto pueden seguir
viendo france24 sigan con nosotros
[Música]